[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti Permettetemi di fare
una
cosa quanto tempo sprechiamo ma
soprattutto dove A far cosa lo
sprechiamo non ci ho messo molto a
trovare una risposta a queste domande Mi
è bastato attraversare momenti miei dei
miei amici dei miei familiari dei miei
clienti e la risposta è arrivata
immediata trasparente
cruda spendiamo gran parte del nostro
tempo cercando di essere chi non siamo
rincorrendo chi pensiamo Dovremmo essere
e raccontandoci per quelli che non
saremo mai in pratica spendiamo gran
parte del nostro tempo nella ricerca
della maschera giusta le maschere in
realtà hanno una funzione adattiva Cioè
ci permettono di sperimentare lati di
noi che altrimenti non verrebbero fuori
quindi ci permettono di adeguarci ad
alcuni contesti e ci permettono di
viverli al meglio quindi possiamo dire
che Real sono
funzionali il problema nasce quando le
Indossiamo troppo a lungo se le
Indossiamo troppo a lungo può capitare
che noi non non riconosciamo più se è
una maschera o il volto e quando io non
riesco più a distinguere tra maschera e
volto posso dirmi di essere nei guai ma
facciamo un passo indietro e cerchiamo
di chiederci perché utilizziamo le
maschere abbiamo detto che dipende dal
contesto e ci sono dei contesti che sono
più semp e dei contesti che sono più
complessi il contesto attuale quello in
cui viviamo oggi è fatto da molte
generazioni diverse a confronto qui ne
vedo qualcuna Quindi vediamo se vi
risuona un
po' vorrei accompagnarvi all'interno
dell'esplorazione di queste generazioni
chi sono abbiamo i boomers i boomers
sono i nati tra il 1946 e il 19 64 a
seguito del boom economico poi abbiamo
la Generazione X nata tra il 65 e l'80
poi abbiamo i millennials che sono nati
tra l'81 e il 96 e ancora la generazione
Z nata tra il 97 e il
2012 i boomers chi sono Sono quelli che
ci dicono cosa dobbiamo essere per i
boomers C'è solo un modo di fare le cose
loro sanno cosa è giusto e cosa è
sbagliato loro sanno che per arrivare da
A a B c'è un solo modo ed è quello
giusto loro ci dicono cosa dovremmo
studiare e in quanto tempo ci dicono che
lavoro dovremmo fare Ci dicono che
dovremmo essere belli performanti in
forma che dovremmo avere un compagno una
compagna un marito dei figli un ottimo
lavoro un buono stipendio Insomma se noi
rispettassi le loro regole saremmo
perfettamente accettati all'interno
della società risponderemo a dei dictat
ma non saremmo altro che delle copie
tutte uguali dello stesso copione delle
copie a cui non è permesso chiedersi ma
io come
sto ma questo era davvero quello che
volevo fare nella vita ed è così che
arrivano i millennials Ecco i
millennials sono quelli che hanno
iniziato a guardarsi allo specchio e non
conoscersi hanno iniziato a sentire la
pelle che tira sotto una maschera
appiccicata male Hanno iniziato a
domandarsi ma era questo il flusso di
vita che mi aspettavo di
percorrere ed è così che hanno iniziato
ad avere il coraggio di togliere e
mettere la maschera la tolgono in
contesti familiari che intendiamoci non
è la famiglia e La indossano ne tti
esterni dove sanno che non verranno mai
accettati per quello che sono davvero ed
è così che oscillano tra metto e tolgo
qualcuno di loro i più coraggiosi
l'hanno tolta e hanno urlato al mondo io
sono così che ti piaccia o no non è un
problema mio Ed ecco che arriva la
generazione Z Ecco la generazione Z ci
sta insegnando una cosa incredibile cioè
che le regole si possono cambiare loro
hanno capito che essere è meglio che
fare loro hanno capito che tutelare se
stessi è la cosa più importante da fare
e non sono disposti ad accettare un
lavoro Cool solo perché devono farlo non
sono disposti a stare a lungo in una
relazione perché Cosa fai dai la butti
via non sono disposti a sottostare ad un
modo di vivere che è sempre stato così
Loro sono capaci di difendere la loro
essenza e il loro benessere al costo di
tutto che in realtà il costo di tutto È
perdere se stessi e quindi loro ci
stanno insegnando che possiamo creare un
mondo di persone
uniche Ma io voglio farci delle domande
abbiamo idea di cosa significhi per i
boomers vivere senza potersi mai
chiedere come sto posso fare altro
sotterrare continuamente le loro
emozioni perché non gli è concesso non
gli è stato concesso tirarle fuori e
abbiamo idea di cosa significhi Invece
per i millennials oscillare tra sono
così ma dovrei essere così tra questo
estremo giudizio verso noi stessi e
abbiamo idea invece di cosa significhi
per i per la generazione Z accettarsi
totalmente per quello che sono e
accettarsi significa accettare le
emozioni positive quanto quelle negative
cioè la tristezza la depressione l'ansia
la
paura e abbiamo idea ancora di dove
Succede questo in un contesto in cui non
è più casa famiglia lavoro
amici ma il mondo dei social media dove
vieni giudicato da un
algoritmo dal numero di post che fanno
Hanno successo da dal numero di like che
hai dal numero di commenti che hai da
quanti posti Cool frequenti quanti amici
famosi hai da quanto spendi per i tuoi
outfit da quante cene riesci a fare ogni
sera e soprattutto da come le fotografi
e come le posti è un algoritmo che ti
dice se puoi diventare virale e poi ti
porta ad essere nessuno alla stessa
velocità un mondo vetrina in cui vediamo
corpi perfetti amori idilliaci
amici
Ino in sentir meno sentir out sentirsi
non all'altezza È
normale Uno in forse la cosa migli che
possiamo augurarci è l'alienazione da sé
Perché tut quello che può produr è Mol
molto peggiore e allora oggi io sono qua
perché voglio chiedere a questo mondo un
atto di coraggio voglio chiedere a
questo mondo di togliere le maschere io
ho tolto le scarpe all'inizio di questo
speech perché le scarpe per me sono
state una
maschera Io ho sempre pensato che una
donna in carriera non poteva che fare
uno speech del genere su dei tacchi 12
D'altronde mi hanno insegnato così ho
camminato su tacchi 12 per anni perché
era giusto così ho lavorato in
consulenza dovevo per forza essere
perfetta anche nell'outfit
ma io odiavo i miei piedi come potevo
non odiarli li costringevo in una
dimensione non propria li mettevo in
delle scarpe che non facevano al loro
caso erano scomode mi facevano male
provare per credere ovviamente
ehm e quindi avevo un rapporto negativo
con i miei piedi fino a quando ho avuto
il coraggio di togliere quella maschera
e e ho capito che i miei piedi a
contatto con la terra mi danno la
possibilità di essere in contatto con me
è come se io prendessi energia dal suolo
e quindi mi sentissi più focalizzata più
stabile è il mio modo di stare ma non lo
avevo scoperto perché avevo una
maschera e quindi come queste maschere
questa piccola maschera noi ne
Indossiamo
infinite ma quanto è difficile davvero
toglierla quanto è difficile davvero
fare uno speech a piedi nudi e allora è
un processo è lungo è faticoso dobbiamo
affrontare le credenze che abbiamo
stratificato per anni dentro di noi ma
si può fare si può fare e io vi auguro
di farlo perché vi permette di scoprire
la vostra vera essenza e credo che non
ci sia un atto più liberatorio di questo
E allora tornando alla mia domanda iale
Cioè quanto tempo sprechiamo Io oggi
vorrei dirvi salviamoci Salviamo il
nostro tempo e chiediamoci sono il volto
o la maschera
[Applauso]
Grazie
n